and yeah so this talk will be actually
mostly based on what I'm doing as a
mentor for this so yeah thanks
[Applause]
you
thanks for being here okay I must to put
this tracking watch so just before we
start I just want to make sure your
expectations are you know that we match
expectations so it's really a beginner
introductory talk on recommender system
it will be mostly focused on collaborate
filtering in matrix factorization so who
have ever heard of the term matrix
factorization okay
among those people who have ever worked
on a recommender system one two three
four five six okay so actually this
tutorial thanks so this rule is not
aimed at you
so either you want to you know make best
use of your time or you want to stay
here and help me if there is any
question or during the hands-on like
make sure that you help your neighbors
around alright so who has never heard
about matrix factorization okay so there
are a few or who have never really
touched recommender system so yeah so
that's tutorial is aimed at you mostly
alright so as we mentioned before I am
the data scientist at booking.com
so that's why I still put like the the
slide of booking that come however this
hands-on is inspired by one of the
project of the program always mentioning
and I booking I'm not working on
recommender systems I work on
experimentation helping teams to assess
the impact of the changes through mostly
be testing and methodologies so yeah
none of this reflect the work we do at
booking and recommender system this
being said I'd like you to actively
participate please ask questions when
you have them let me know if you don't
follow or if you don't understand
something chances chances are if you
don't understand probably your neighbor
doesn't understand either
so to raise your hand and ask
yeah let me know when you're on photo
and help each other during the hands-on
so what is a recommends system I'll just
define it as a type of information
filter which aims at proposing relevant
pieces of information so for instance
when you are Netflix you'll be proposed
a few more movies to watch when you go
on amazon.com you'll see our product
that you might be interested in if you
go on a travel on online travel agents
then you'll be proposed like recommended
properties to go or even destinations
during this talk I'll be mentioning
ratings so ratings could be could have
many forms and I just like have a
distinction between two so it's an
expression of users interest you can
have explicit feedback like you asked
someone to write a movie and put stars
you ask someone to rate a nap on the on
the App Store yeah sweet it requires
some kind of active action from the user
but we also have available something
like implicit feedback so link to
passive actions to the behavior so if
someone browse the website and see one
page rather than another click on some
kind of awesome button look at products
to frequency they come back so all of
this can give us also kind of an
implicit rating implicit feedback and
also locking there are many many
different kinds of recommender systems
we also took some time about ranking
ranking method ranking algorithms so
here I'm just focusing on two big kind
of recommender system one kind which is
called content based so we don't really
care about user interaction with your
website or your product we only look at
what products you have so you might have
movies you might have
product like on an e-commerce you might
have I don't know a news website with
articles these are so kind of products
and so the content based methods to
recommend systems they just try to find
similarities between the products you
have so you could look at for a movie
you could look at the budget you could
look at the actors you could look at the
generals and etc etc and to find
similarities we can use neighborhood
methods so really looking for similarity
between products or clustering methods
another big big kind of recommender
systems is called collaborative
filtering and it is based on the
religious social interaction of the
users so it's really how user interact
with with your website have the browser
products and so on and among this big
big like group there are eight three
that were kind of popularized user based
so you look for similar users from this
user item interaction item base you look
for similar items together and mattress
factorization is you look at well you
try to to kill to two birds at once
terms so you really try to recommend the
best product to the user given the past
interaction of all users with all the
products so are just if I take those
four examples I'd like you maybe to tell
me whether it's implicit or explicit
feedback and whether it's content-based
or collaborative filtering and if you
can maybe tell me which kind of
collaborative filtering it is so Netflix
here because you watched stranger things
then we're proposing you those films
what would it be would it be implicit or
explicit implicit feedback yeah someone
who would fall for explicit no yeah this
is really we didn't ask the user here to
to rate something but we just observed
the the behavior of the user you watch
this movie
and probably using an item item
collaborative filtering method then we
come up with recommendations Amazon
customers reviewed this item also viewed
those items again it is implicit
feedback and what kind of system would
it be sorry I don't hear sorry yeah well
actually here you still have the
customers so so you probably have used
some kind of user item metrics or user
hampton lists so it's still
collaborative filtering and also
actually probably item based and the
last one so online travel agent out
topic so here i don't know i co can you
still interested in Furman Austin so
what would this one be yeah it's not
maybe obvious it's is still implicit
feedback so actually most of the cases
here I gave you our implicit feedback
it means like we got a huge quality of
data from that and this one seems like
very personalized like it's me it's not
like anyone else it's not like those
customers who you'd like it's me sorry
let me and it's probably something that
use either matrix factorization I don't
know exactly but it's really trying to
make the most use of the information
user item information so now we'll dive
in right into collaborate really
filtering most of it will be about
matrix factorization
but first so what do we say why do we
say collaborative filtering so actually
the start of this kind of methods is
having a list of ratings so you have a
list of pairs user item to which you
have a necessity rating so here again
this rating could be
got explicitly so here I think I just
got a rating from for instance a movie
databases where people actually clicked
on it but you could come with some kind
of rating with maybe the frequency of
viewing such a page or something like
that
so it doesn't have to be explicit and so
yeah you see that so let's say it is
sorted by by user ID so okay user one as
as rated to items user 2 as rated one
item and well none of it is coming with
with user 1 user 57 as rated three items
who and one of them actually two of them
are coming with user one and from this
what you want to get or maybe it's
easier to represent it you just pivot I
know is anyone not familiar with Tempe
but it's okay please raise your hand no
one's raising their hand while I'm pivot
pivoting a table so so you're not
beginners you eat [ __ ] all right okay
all right so you get so yeah
so by pivoting this on on user items and
then filling it with the ratings so
filling it with ratings yeah so you get
what we call a sparse matrix meaning
that's most of it is actually non filled
most of it is missing values but you
have a few a few values that are not
missing and that's the information you
get and like so you got this and this is
the base of many collaborations in
methods so one of them that were I was
mentioning I will be very quickly on it
is the user base methods so here you
would consider that so you focus freely
on the users and you will consider all
the items so it could be the movies that
they rated and so you see that you have
a few ratings a few missing ones
I mean actually a lot of missing ones
but here you will consider that the
items are kind of features and you will
use these features to find the
similarity between users so you will
take for instance user 1 and user 57 you
will compute some kind of distant
between the two usually we do use cosine
distance and you will come up with that
user 1 user 57 path with this value here
and you do the same for all pairs of
users and you end up with symmetric
matrix
which gives you kind of the correlation
between users and from that then you can
work on building a recommendation you
you know user you see how similar it is
to another user this other user has like
these other products and then you can
you can you can recommend those of the
products to the first one so yeah you
start from a end user by n items metric
and you end up with a smidge a symmetric
matrix n user item base is actually the
opposite this time these are these are
you focus on the items and all the users
are actually kind of features you do the
same you you take two items for instance
item 1 item 2 you try to find a
similarity between these two vectors and
you find value here and you end up with
symmetric matrix of n items and from
that you can find you can recommend
products that are similar to some
product that you've browsed but the last
method that's I'm going to present today
and that's the one we'll spend most of
our time today as matrix decomposition
so you start from the same sparse matrix
user item and again it's a sparse metric
it's mostly filled with zeros eventually
what we will want to do is to fill all
these missing values
[Music]
by doing so I mean or what we why do we
say mattress the concision because most
of the methods try to focus on finding a
matrix of users and matrix of items that
define the items and trying to like the
product should give you something close
to the first mattress so you start with
end-user buy an item mattress you and
you try to decompose it in so some kind
of user metrics and item mattress and
the nice trick is so it's a space metric
so you should be able to find a lower
rank mattress missing a mattress that
contains here you have like MIDI
dimensions for users media dimension for
items but actually the user or the items
could may be defined by in in a smaller
dimensional place like a space with
smaller dimensions so okay this is up to
you to define or optimize this number of
factors we call them a Latin Factory
the kind of like hidden hidden property
of a product so if you think of a movie
once you've let's say trying an
algorithm to do this maybe so you get
one factor maybe this is around maybe
okay how how much this this movie
contains like action or how much this
movie I don't know how old sorry yeah
maybe like so generous but maybe it
could be okay it's like a blockbuster or
something around I don't know it has
been directed by like very famous like
director or yeah but we don't know
actually
so just the algorithm we try to find the
most relevant hidden features given this
yes
yes you have to define it but you can
also I try to optimize it yeah that
that's something that you define somehow
beforehand but when you do so this I
didn't mention before so you have the
content based methods that are mostly
unsupervised you try to find
similarities between well yeah between
products and this method is a supervised
method so you can really try to to split
between try try and validation tests and
try to optimize on the arrow to get a
nice I mean an optimized number of
factors I don't know if it answers your
question yeah
so I touched a bit so how to interpret
the user in item matrices so here all
the all the columns would correspond to
some hidden factors and it's a
characteristic an item can possess and
the user can be susceptible to if I take
user u so this value in the for for the
factor K is how much the user U is
acceptable to this characteristic K or
how much it is important to them
similarly if I take for item I this
value here will represent how much this
item possess like hum how much of this
characteristic the item I so one okay
like if you've done I don't know some
kind of scientific curriculum at some
point you've you've come up with one way
to to do match with the composition and
it is called SVD for singular vector
value sorry singular value decomposition
and it's exactly on paper it seems to be
doing exactly what we want which is come
up with a lower rank approximation of of
the of the first mattress
so we're able to decompose the user item
mattress into a user mattress and vector
mattress and these are orthogonals and
we also find the eigen values of the
original mattress so that's yeah let's
say we want to try this like just to get
some rating data pivot and get the user
item mattress and then apply SVD let's
try that so here is a short link I can
also copy paste it in the slack Channel
oh yeah before so who doesn't have
access to collaboratory okay one two did
you manage to download a two to install
the required packages dammit I put like
you know you know long list to make sure
people we go to collaboratory but okay
it's okay just just go ahead you have
the two links and also while you connect
could you check that you have access to
the slack Channel so I created a
tutorial one rexis channel so that's
maybe again could be based a few things
there
it's this tutorial one Rix's thank you
seven people are 70 16 people I think
there we miss a few more in the channel
so I'll just put so I leave it on the
screen who hasn't been able to upend our
notebook yet just to to see how fast a
few more so I leave this do you need the
link still okay
sorry you got it see nice but I okay the
people who didn't connect are you able
to connect now good
if you don't you didn't bring your
laptop I see actually most of you did
please make friends with your neighbor
ask if you can you know have a look at
what they're doing and I see new
friendship you know starting here Oh
so I remember there are a few people who
might get bored because it's it yeah
because they've already worked on
recommender system so I've come up with
a little game here so there are a few
flows in the notebook it's not like I'm
aware of some of them some I might not
be aware of my idea for this notebook
was to get you let's say build from
scratch like only using Mumbai mostly
first you know matrix factorization
algorithm so I did make a few short
shortcuts or stuff so the game is if you
detect like some of the flaws or like
some you know bias that are there you
get one point sorry all right so yeah if
you get one point if you find a flow if
you think you find a flow but it's not
you you lose two points if you're able
to actually find a solution or a fix
then you get a random number of points
with an unknown probability distribution
and if you reach minus five please you
know you out of the game and so the game
what you gain I'll pay a drink to
whoever you know it was the most points
after this game and also a I have the
right to stop the game whenever I want
no we keep the scores right it's not
yeah or like to you know to postpone it
to after the talk
all right so I hope everyone has
connected yes okay no someone
its accelerated yeah so it's by data the
the network and it's thank you.thank so
you should have this notebook here so
all right so we'll just import a few
libraries you might not need Seaborn but
it's a nice situation that library so
let's try it with this yeah all right
is there anyone not being able to
connect or having an unfriendly neighbor
then it doesn't want to you know to work
together no one perfect so yeah so we
just imported libraries and we input the
data so you just have to click and maybe
you want to know what the data looks so
you have two two matrices or two data
frames in that case one will give you
some information about the movie so it
gives you the movie ID I recall it item
ID the title and the generous we won't
mostly use this for the recommender
system because this is about matrix
factorization so will mostly use the
second one which gives you so the user
item interaction so one row will give
you the rating that the user gave to an
item your time stamp you might not need
it but maybe it will be useful if you
want to cut the data or to get the most
recent data or something I won't be
using it so now your work is I give you
five yeah five five minutes
five ten minutes I don't know to do a
quick exploration so you know go wild
do as as you wish don't hesitate to use
as many cells as you need
I'll give you a few hints here if you've
never used pandas or matplotlib or
Seabourn before and only state use the
duck or use your neighbors yeah so I
don't know what you would like to be
interested as I don't know what's the
range of of the rating what's the range
of the user ID and item ID I would yeah
I would encourage you to focus mostly on
the DF ratings data frame good that's
the one we'll be looking at most
so I don't know what do they do
there's a nice function called describe
that gives you like some stats on the
data
okay it's too late but I had a few USB
keys for anyone who could not connect to
Wi-Fi or get up or something so and we
should crash if the computer questions
is someone like really stuck like I have
no idea where they different is please
you know speak I can send you one of
your you know bollocks
all right yes oh sorry I didn't I didn't
say so you please don't go go further
like just do your explorations and then
that's all this will do right after so
are you happy with your exploration with
like super proud of of their exploration
like you know you've you've done a
scatter whatever pairwise scatter plot
or you've done like really nice string
string rough from say Seaborn you've
done okay someone mildly happy with the
exploration all right not helping all
right so I love to do I won't do
anything like very fancy I don't know
you know much time anyway so I'll just
get for instance the histogram of of the
ratings just you to know like how they
are distributed so a very quick way to
do this in suspenders is just to take
the data frame that the column name dot
hist okay so yeah
only thing is okay it seems we have
half-integer integers values of rating
so maybe I should say which range I want
so a range of I think so like from the
describe I can see that the minimum
rating is 0.5 and the maximum is 5 so
I'll just get something around it so 0
maybe 6 and then I want to go every
point 5
doesn't start well between what and what
oh yeah bins I have to say what it is
bins I want those bins yeah so yeah just
like this for eating it seems we we we
have a subset of users who are very nice
and don't don't put very negative
ratings of movies I didn't mention this
data set comes from the movie lands
database so it's a its website has
fitted to a research group and they
develop like we're gonna system and you
can actually log into this website
create your account rate rate movies and
get personalized recommendations so it
seems like those users on this website
don't put low scores but mostly for and
take I know the graph maybe you want to
do look at this time stamps you could
try to find some some kind of very fancy
and say like use for instance the day
time library to convert those time
stamps into extra dates I won't do that
I will just try to have an idea of their
like three partition of the time stamps
and then okay so it seems fairly uniform
for this period of time and what
happened there maybe they stopped the
website for some time and you see like
more usage or more waiting at least
being given there so for me that's all
that's let's say what I wanted to know
is like the range of the rating how like
like how its distributed and what's the
yeah what's the age let's say or what's
the distribution in time of the of the
ratings did someone come up with like an
interesting things to visualize or to
explore no okay yes
okay
possibly yes and in what sense which so
in the frequency of the user so you
group nice well are using collaboratory
are you using collaborate three or did
you put it on your own laptop would you
like to share the link in the slack so
that people can just see how nice plots
you got yeah thanks so you just click on
the share it's like a Google Doc white
so you click on share and maybe view or
something and then you give the link in
the slack channel then you'll be able to
see it very nice like per voice thank
you very much you know interactive yeah
so once
so once week that actually what we are
interested in if you remember here I've
told you that the first step for
collaborating filtering methods is to
get the user item mattress from the list
of ratings so that's what you do at the
next line so here just try to find a way
to get this user item mattress from the
rating mattress
if you're bored you can you know share
your awesome plots you can check his to
some plots you can play the little game
I gave you we can look a few as well so
what we want is to get to gf ratings and
pivot and so I don't know I don't
exactly the format of it but in the
Jupiter notebook there is a very nice
thing when you open a bracket and you
click tab then you got the documentation
in line so okay
the index the index would be the rows so
I want I want the rows to be the user LT
is the column and I want it to be the
item IDs and the value I'd like it to be
the ratings so I'll just write that down
so we said index user ID column I guess
we have to put it in and values
and this should work anyone would like
me to copy paste it in the in the slack
or yes okay
yep so if you look get it I don't want
to lose anyone that's the beginner
tutorial right so if you look at what it
looks like well it does look like a
sparse matrix a lot of missing values
written as none
you can look maybe at the describe so
again what this matrix represents is
just it's another way of writing the the
rating lists so we got for a given user
so user 1 for instance we get all the
ratings this user gave to all the films
we got in the dataset
something we didn't maybe check before
so you have about 10,000 column that
means you got 10,000 films rated if you
checked a bit before I think here it
tells you that it is until you here but
you have about 600 users or so yeah
eventually what we want to do is I don't
remember how many rows there was in the
ratings
I think it's written maybe there if you
do ratings shape
so yeah 100 100,000 ratings so they're
on average like about 10 ratings per
user and we got what did we say we got
we got ten thousand three we get 10,000
ratings
so there's sorry ten thousand movies
six hundred users so we get about sorry
six million rows there are 6 million
values in this matrix and we got only a
hundred thousand of them so it's it's
really like not field it doesn't seem
like it's like a hundred thousand
ratings seems to be a lot but eventually
what we want to feel it's like most of
the values here in this matrix so just
to give you an idea of the complexity of
the task so anyway let's go quick so if
I just take one one user already then
this row will tell me all the ratings
that to use it it and all the movie
generated so let's take the first ten
movies for user 1 so we see okay rated
movie 1 3 & 6 don't do that you can save
that fully like you can save maybe the
already rated IDs for later and what we
want to do the purpose of this is to
find a matrix of lower you know rank
that means like rank is not a dimension
but that means that the information that
this mattress gets is could actually be
shrinked to like some kind of objective
of dimension K like a smaller dimension
so we if we want to apply like basically
just SVD so singular value decomposition
algorithm we can't do it on a sparse
metric we need all the values to be
filled so what may be happened like 10
20 years ago people would try to find a
way to apply just
force SVD to twist kind of problem and
it will be like what should I put in the
non in the missing values and they come
up with okay we put zeros or will put
the mean of all values so that's what
I'm you know you know let's try
something so let's let's fill it with
zero so that's the function feel missing
value fill in a with zero and you got a
mattress with a lot of zeros now here
we'll just put it in array so it's the
same thing just it's not data from
anymore and this allows us to use SVD
from Sify off from numpy so that's this
library the nice thing about the
stepwise version is you can tell them
you can tell the function the number of
hidden factors you want so here I put 15
it's quite quick actually it's quite
efficient for this amount of data and
what do so we got the matrix u Sigma and
V so these are sorry these matrices here
who you know who puts animation on the
sides okay so yeah so that's this
mattress and we get two orthogonal
matrices u in V and a list of
eigenvalues so you good this mattress
use a mattress the list of eigenvalues
and this and how would you get
recommendations well it's a bit tricky
right I'm doing oh here is this matrix
please get a factor of factorize it so
get me two matrices U and V so that the
product gives there in the mattress and
here what we want to get is the matrix
back so yeah basically we just want to
lose that product or like the the matrix
the mattress multiplication of those two
matrices and this is all here oops
did something wrong oh yeah thanks yeah
so yeah Sigma is here just a list of of
eigenvalues but what we want is a is a
diagonal matrix filled with the diagonal
filled with these these values okay so
yeah here you got it maybe you want to
put it in some kind of a data frame
format so pandas that data frame of that
okay it's just a bit nicer so it is the
same as before if you look at if you try
to compare this mattress and the first
one it actually a bit off and and why
would it be that doesn't count as a flow
right I mean I know it's fluid so I tell
I told it first yes yeah well that would
be the case for any matrix factorization
we will try to find a representation
that it's a Tecla space takes less
actual meaning meaningful dimensions so
no that's not it well here basically we
just said here at this line we filled
all the unknown ratings with zero
meaning that we just assumed that users
would put would rate very badly all
those movie they didn't see which might
seems of right and then we apply SVD to
that to get well back something similar
like so that's the the two matrices we
got give by like if you get the
predictive a to give the the ratings so
theoretically this would read as user 0
rated movie to with I mean would write
the movie - with this rating user 5 Road
route would rate
film movie 4 with this rating and so on
but it just like a very rough method
like tactic so the missing values are so
this is feedback that user did not give
and we cannot say that it's even worse a
negative the lowest rating actually is
0.5 and we put 0 through 7 words the
other problem is it's the dance matrix
and applying SVD to it is not scalable
so here it's actually very small data
set you if you run a website you you
hope I mean I I wish you have more than
600 I mean it depends but if you want to
do recommendation let's say you want
more than 600 visitors or users actually
would say you're logged in users because
visitors alone it's hard to track them
right and items
well maybe 10,000 items is reasonable to
start with but let's say like if you
want to feel and apply a SVD to a bigger
and the great bigotry it just doesn't
scale it doesn't work so what we do is
we'll touch on trying to get an
approximate matrix factorization using
gradient descent
I don't want to go through this so just
who is not familiar with gradient
descent okay there's a few people thank
you like you know you didn't cheat
everyone else did
so anyway for YouTube and me before we
want to refresh I'll just explain what
the gradient descent is so you have a
function okay we start with Wendy you
have a function with one parameter this
function can have any in shape usually
what we're interested in is for instance
a measure of a loss of when you have an
algorithm so the loss with different
sense the difference between what you
predict and the real value it doesn't
have to be convex convent's means that
if you take one point anywhere on the
curve and another point then it
shouldn't cross the the function itself
like the curve itself here it's not the
case like ideally yes all the hypotheses
all the assumptions state that you
should have a conveyance from this one
it's not the case so yeah that's why it
look like a random function but what we
want to do is to find a minimum or the
minimum the like a local minimum or the
general minimum of this function so what
we start the gradient descent approach
is you randomly initialize the parameter
theta so you just take one one point on
the on the parameter space so you get
the evaluation of F on that on that
point and then you do it you have a data
set so here we have for instance the the
rating the ratings and then you here I
will do it row by row so we holy
stochastic will just we will update the
value of the optimal theta for each for
each row and maybe I can look at the
data set only one time but maybe I want
to do many times so here for a given
amount of time I will
compute the D rate of F on theta so it
is basically the slope the slope of the
curve on theta here it's a negative
slope okay and then you update theta
with the following rule you move theta
from minus alpha alpha is what we call
the nearing rate is just a step like
it's like a step in the algorithms
multiply it by the the gradient so
multiplied by the direction of theta of
the story of the of the derivate of F
and theta so here this is negative it's
a negative slope minus alpha so you know
that you have to increase increase theta
that's why like okay you go from this
point to this point okay so and then
what you do you repeat so you get a
slope again so you get the red and you
update you what happens when you don't
have one parameter but many parameters
so here you have a function a function
of many parameters theta sit okay so
here I'll just stick to dimension see
that one and see that you well you
actually basically do the same you
randomly initialize all this theta so
you take one point in this hyper space
you compute so this time so for given
for a given amount of time for all
parameters you try to compute you
compute the partial derivative of F on
theta K and you update the theta K with
this rule so theta K minus alpha of the
parcel by the partial derivative on
theta game and so this way you actually
why we call it gradient descent I mean
region because we compute the gradient
and descent because that's really like
going down valley you're going down a
ball or something you retry to go down
to find the direction where you fall so
your best friend here is gravity so you
imagine you here and you just let you
fall and and then that's one way of
finding the local minimum so now we want
to apply this to finding a factorization
of the initial matrix of the initial
spare mattress so this time we do not
feel the missing values that's important
like we said okay it's by its fluid is
biased we don't want to reduce feedback
this way so we do it a bit differently
so we won't go for orthogonal matrices
there are a few assumption that won't
hold anymore but we still want just a
mattress multiplication of user metrics
by item address so you initialize this
item and user matrices so the values in
them with random values so that's your
parameter theta you compute the
predicted rating which is the product of
the user and the item address you
compute the error but the error is the
difference between the predicted rating
so you take user I and a user you and
item I you multiply the two hidden
vector or Latin vector representation of
those user and item any computer
difference and that's basically you
compute the difference with the actual
rating you know so this you know you do
it only on the on on the ratings you you
know of you use the same update role and
you iterate until well until you've
you've tired of looking at the data or
until you reach some kind of threshold
like the or goes beyond some threshold
so here so do date roll so the parameter
theta corresponds to the weights of the
user and item matrices the function will
minimize here is the sum of squared
error is quite weak we could call it
loss it's quite common in supervised
learning
and this is exactly what I said so our
UI are the ratings that we know are is
the set of rating that's have been
provided by the users and you compute
the predicted rating for this user
and in this item computer difference
that's error you square and that's like
you sum over all the ratings you know
and that's how you get the the last
sorry the function you you want to find
an optimal point so what you're
interested in is the partial derivative
on the on the parameters so the user
weight and the item weights you do some
magic and that's what you get for for
each of the partial derivative so if I
inject back in the endo algorithm again
you initials the value all the values of
the of the user and item address you do
n passes on the data we call it an epoch
usually when we look once into all the
rows that's one epoch and we do it maybe
one two three times or more for all
known ratings then you update PU and you
we obtain the job three you update the
parameters so the weight of the matrices
using this rule and with this I let you
go back to the
so yeah it just like repeating oh I'm
very sorry I think I didn't give you the
know it's here it's okay it could act as
a flu yes I call yeah because I didn't
want to we don't need the word
stochastic but stochastic um not
necessarily stochastic is just like you
updates at each at each provide each
data point versus batch gradient descent
or mini-batch gradient where you'll
update every every ten ten data points
or every set of points so when and nd so
that's one extreme so you updates each
for each row and usually it's very
chaotic so for instance we could go one
direction and we go back to one
direction and would go back to another
direction versus if like the other
extreme would be you update you just do
one step but for each step you look at
all the data and this is much smoother
but also much longer to process so that
would be most of here I don't that's a
good question I'm not trying to to avoid
that right now or for me it would be
like from more advanced step but indeed
we we not we're not free from from that
people
so this function you might not need to
know exactly what it does but it will
help the algorithm a bit later because
if you look at the data maybe if you
plotted all the ideas of the of the
movies for instance with the items you
see that it's not continuous you miss a
few so just to help it I do a mapping
between the the IDS and the range of 1
to the number of of item IDs for
instance so you don't have to like look
deep in this one what's on the other and
what you should look at it is I just put
the summary of the within of the
procedure and I asked you to fill in the
blanks here so find the number of users
and number of items of unique users and
items in the data try to understand so
we randomly initialize the user and item
matrices we will look at a certain
amount of a POC by default I put 3
because I it's already quite long to run
you look at all rows in the data set you
get the user ID item ID for this row the
rating for this row and then your job is
to calculate the error and once we got
here--oh then you can do the graduated
date the parameter update who has done
it routine ok so I'll let you
what should help you is really this
that's what you re trying to to
implement
so yeah I was told that yes indeed if I
just write those two lines in code then
so I update pew and then I'll bet you Qi
but Qi also asked for PU and in that
case I would update it on the on the
already data value of P you so one way
is to store the all value of ki of P you
first and then and then use the P you
old here I H I would think that on the
long run it should give approximately
same result but if you want you to do it
properly then you should store their old
p value so I'm writing it here just like
P old and just make sure that's here you
use P old instead of of PU
and I had a question also why why do why
do we use PU and Qi like in interpret Li
so that's really because of the of the
partial derivative which is here so when
you compute the relative of the last
function over P you then you got the
error term and the error term actually
contains a product of those two
parameters and you end up with both PU
and Qi in both partial derivative so who
has finished this part three four five
okay six then you can also like get the
estimate function just below you want
and you get you gave a fix as well
Caroline's what's the run done you know
it's Cory good
so let me maybe give you the like one
way of doing it so what we were missing
is the number of users because the
number of users an item will help us
build the Latin matrices so one we have
to do that is just to look so data is
the data frame you can you can get all
the user ID from the data frame and just
ask the number of unique elements the
same way for a number of items so during
the gradient descent you need the error
function so it's really the difference
between the known the non waiting the
the real waiting - the prediction of it
and the prediction is the product
between for a given user and a given
item the product of the due to lighten
the two hidden vectors and the update
rule here I just like copy the formula
here pee-yew plus alpha learning rate
and that I am in here so it's also Qi
plus alpha by the error by so I would
have put PU but actually PU is already
updated so I put P old but it's
basically just alright yeah okay yeah no
you write things so you can you can you
can use unique just touch unique and
then lengths or just directly and unique
and so when so let's say so this
function will actually give you out of
this parse metric the the user and the P
and Q mattress so the user and item
addresses and to then from this mattress
get an estimate of the rating that user
you would give to the movie I or the
item I given those matrices then you
just do the scalar product of the
vectors for you and I
q by the transpose would anyone need me
to put it on slack okay yeah at least
one person so I just put those just
check that it works yes it works
so yeah just do it here because
thank God your looks like this and the
updates is and the estimate would be
this okay it's a bit brutal to just go
Peter had the best known the few lines
but I hope you got it
alright so let's compute it maybe I
should have asked you to do it before
but it takes a few minutes to do
so actually can cheat and take another
notebook that is already here yes yes
it's another approach indeed I'm not
familiar with it no I just know it's
another way to do you know how to change
the algorithms to do so would it be like
in a few lines of code
yeah all these videos so the question
was about using a truncated SVD instead
of SVD and it's indeed faster okay I
just use let's say the first that I come
across so that so it takes a bit of time
to run even for three bucks but then
yeah then what we want to get is an
estimate for all user item pairs so for
that it's the only thing that you need
to do is to do the dot product of these
two matrices and when you look at it
then we'll go to nicely filled mattress
you can
the only thing is now you just because I
had done a mapping of the IDS you need
to get the mapping back so that's what
this line is doing and well you just
kind of apply it and then okay
eventually you get the user item
mattress with the proper user IDs and an
item IDs now I'm just going to run
quickly the end of the notebook because
I didn't I didn't want to torture you
further the rest of it so and I didn't
put too much comments as well so if you
want now to see the original waiting for
the user one so it's what we did before
so here is not nice it should be na is
missing values so but yeah basically you
had four ratings and now if you look at
the new user item mattress that you
filled you get all the IDS filled so you
can look for and then a new mattress
give you 4.2 you had four also here now
it give you 3.6 okay you had six here
you add 4 here and gives you four point
seven so yeah it's not an ideal so maybe
we need some there many things we will
need actually this is like the the
minimal version I could come up with an
approximate SVD approach procedure but
you would want possibly to add
regularization you won't want you to
have tools to easily split into training
validation set and maybe optimize some
of the hyper parameters so upper
branches could be the number of epochs
the number of hidden features the
learning rate for instance so I didn't
ask you to do it from scratch but we'll
see how to do it later now that you got
this user item mattress filled you want
to give recommendations and for that for
instance you just take all the predicted
ratings for user 1 so for that you just
do like one you sort them so you put the
just predicted movie isn't up and for
instance we take the tent first the ten
highest predicted rated movies you got
movie IDs here and then that's now where
you can use the movie database
information to look at what they look
like so these are the recommendations so
this user liked very own movies I mean
seems to that's what we predict sir so
we propose to this user very old movies
around a big drama action drama drama
drama drama okay
maybe it's nice to look at what was
already rated by this user so you just
do the same exactly the same but with
the the first with user item mattress
with a lot of missing values you sort
them and you get this and doesn't look
at its superb superbly done right I
don't see drama a single time yeah so
what could have we done better better
few ideas maybe we didn't train it
enough maybe just three passes on the
day is not enough maybe actually I
didn't look at the other weights
carefully but maybe there are a few
there is some of a fitting actually on
the opposite side on the data so for
that we need regularization that means
try to really meet the range of the
parameters so that there's not a few of
them that is driving them the prediction
we could optimize on the DI parameters
maybe there is a set of hyper parameters
that works better so yeah to put this in
production we need separate training in
validation sets and for that I propose
you to use actually now a library so you
have mini under markets I used a
surprise because it is really dedicated
to recommender system and Python it is
quite easy to read and understand the
code so yeah so you need to insulate so
on collaborator it works smoothly it
might not be the case on your laptop
sorry for that
so basically surprise allows you to to
define a data structure that gets a
rating so here I define the reader and I
just need to tell them to tell it what's
the range of the rating and then I can
import directly the data frame with
rating in through this this format I can
apply as VD to it I can do
cross-validation it's just a nice way of
getting your data set into train and
validation set but instead of just doing
one split you do rotating splits so we
do get in five and then you train with
some of the five and you test on the
rest and you rotate and then a very nice
thing you can do with this you can like
if you've used a sake turn before you
can do the same procedure so define try
to come up with better hyper parameters
so better number of epochs better
learning rate for instance and you can
optimize on root mean square error or
Mac Mini absolute error here I will just
pick the best parameters for root mean
square error and then you have so once
you got your best parameters so that's
what they do here I get the best
rameters from the grid search before
then we can retrain on the whole data
set with the these separate parameters
that you defined so that's what's being
done here and then you can use the
product function for a given user so for
instance for user it takes some time
sorry for that
the funny thing is so the predict
function works for you would expect that
it works only for user and items that
are seen in it in the database actually
not so I try to use it on for instance a
user that is not in the data set and it
still gives me so a recommendation so
that's the predicted value and why is
that because actually the procedure in
this library it doesn't only give you
predict values for a given item user but
it has also baselines so there is a
journal basslines let's say the average
it probably the exact is the average but
let's say baseline for all movies or
users so actually if you put a user a no
no user any known under unknown item it
will still give you baseline value yes
if you give it no an unknown user and
known item it will give you the baseline
of a resource plus the baseline for this
movie and oppositely if you give an
known user but an unknown item it will
give you the baseline for this
particular user so it is a nice way to
even give a first try first estimate
even if you don't have like data like
for a new movie or for a new user coming
on your website
so that's so I take I take one user so
the first user ID one I look at what
this user rated before so I take the ten
best ratings and I see okay drama drama
again I copied this from the surprise
documentation and this gives us the top
let's say ten for instance prediction
for this user so I built a test set
which is only the values we don't know
that we that were not present in there
in the rating list before and yeah I was
a bit lazy so I just here to see the
nice mattress I just copy pasted the
list of user IDs into the data families
so I let you run and then like compare
you should see a nicer much let's say
between the already rated movies and the
predicted ones and to wrap up what we've
done so we had a list of user of rating
so user rate this movie with this score
that was the DF ratings data frame we
divided it to get another presentation
so during the user item mattress what we
wanted to get is up three relevant
prediction for all the missing values
and we need so by applying a great
indecent procedure one of the usual
problem with with with collaborative
filtering is what do you do with users
so what do you do with new products so I
showed you a way here you can still get
baseline and predict for instance for a
new user coming what let's say the
average of the baseline for that other
users predicted and this we can all do
it as a byproduct of this factorization
another way is well you can ask ok I I
just looked in like created an
accountant movie lines and then the
first thing it does please eat pull it
you wouldn't allow me to go further
please write those movies or
give the score you would give those
group of movies and that's a way of
getting initial information yeah
another way we try to get implicit
feedback from the users who lets him
browse a bit just see which movie
Rosie's in zone I'll go for that so I'll
the aim was really to get you built from
scratch one one factorization procedure
then we used one library true to speed
up and n2 in to ease the process now if
you are interested to actually use the
state-of-the-art techniques I know of
there might be others but I know of
these three approaches so I bleep your
triplet law so Bayesian I don't know
what assistance of law ranking package
is very very well done and to recreate
from Apple is also a very advanced
package and I'm sorry about this I can
send you a notebook if you are
interested in checking a content-based
approach but it was a bit ambitious to
to try to cover both so yeah some frozen
comes mattress factorization gives you
relevant predictions for a given
specific user but it's Confessional
expensive it's hard to work with sparse
matrices and it's hard to start with new
users with new products but there are
some some ways to go through and now
well I hope you enjoyed and you're not
too bored please reach out to me on
slack if you have more questions where
she won't let the user notebook please
try to run a notebook with you on
dataset at home and please also try
those awesome libraries so I'll give you
a link to this presentation and you can
directly click on the notebook and
laboratory and then run them so very
easy and many things
I hope you were able to ask the question
during the talk otherwise I'll be just
right outside